Hallo meine Lieben!
Heute gibt's eine richtig hübsche und leckere Torte,
wir machen einen Schoko Naked Cake mit einer leckeren Sahne-Creme und frischen Früchten.
Also für mich perfekte Komponenten vereint! So, ich zeig euch jetzt zuallererst einen sehr speziellen
Schokoladenboden, ich leg auch direkt los. Die Zutaten habe ich hier bereit stehen
und ihr könnt die ganz genauen Mengenangaben unten in der Videobeschreibung nachlesen.
Jetzt arbeite ich heute mit meiner Küchenmaschine aber ihr könnt auch
wie immer euer Handrührgerät verwenden.
Und jetzt nehm ich mir zuallererst mein Eiweiß. Wichtig ist, dass ihr das sauber trennt,
da sollten keine Eigelb-Reste mehr drin sein.
Die gebe ich jetzt hier einmal in meine Rührschlüssel,
geb da jetzt die Hälfte des Zuckers mit hinzu
und dann schlage ich das so ungefähr 4min lang richtig schön steif. Es kann euch auch helfen, wenn ihr erstmal
ohne Zucker anfangt zu schlagen und dann nach und nach den Zucker einrieseln lasst.
Und entstanden ist eine schöne feste Baisermasse, die gebe ich ganz kurz an die Seite,
hab jetzt eine neue Rührschüssel auf die Küchenmaschine gesetzt und jetzt nehme ich
meinen Rührhaken, das finde ich immer am besten geeignet wenn man Butter cremig schlagen möchte.
So, da gebe ich jetzt die Butter rein. Die sollte bestenfalls zimmerwarm sein,
nicht zu kalt aus dem Kühlschrank. Da kommt jetzt die restliche -
der restliche Zucker mit dazu und dann schlagen wir das so ungefähr 4min
und ihr werdet merken, dass die Butter richtig schön hell-cremig sein wird.
Im nächsten Schritt rühren wir schon mal die Eigelbe ein und ich mache es auch immer so,
dass ich die trockenen Zutaten, nämlich Mehl, Speisestärke, Back-Kakao und Backpulver
vorab miteinander verrühre denn jetzt kommen die trockenen Zutaten einmal in die Butter-Eigelb Masse
aber ganz ganz wichtig: ich hab hier auch noch ein bisschen Milch und wir geben das immer
abwechselnd hinein. Also nicht erst die trockenen Zutaten und dann die Milch, sonst haben wir Klümpchen.
Und wenn ihr alle Schritte beachtet,
dann habt ihr später einen richtig schönen saftigen Schokoteig!
So, jetzt haben wir hier die fertige Buttermasse und die Baisermasse.
Jetzt ist es ganz wichtig, dass wir die Baisermasse
in 2-3 Schritten am besten mit einem Teigschaber unterheben.
(H: Lass mich raten: mit Liebe unterheben!)
Mit ganz viel Liebe!
Mein Schokoladenteig ist jetzt fast fertig, jetzt kommt nur noch eine Zutat mit hinzu
und zwar nehme ich heute die Double Choc Waffeln von Loacker.
Und ich bin ganz ehrlich: ich bin total froh über die Zusammenarbeit denn ihr wisst ja
ich gucke ja immer auch so auf den Background der Firmen und Loacker
das ist eben ein Familienunternehmen aus Südtirol.
Und ich habe mir mal die Zutatenliste hinten auch durchgelesen und hier steht Bourbon-Vanilleschote,
das heißt kein künstliches Vanillin. Ich kennt mich ja mittlerweile: also ich bin ja gar kein Fan von
künstlicher Vanille. Und wenn ihr da auf hochwertige Zutaten achten möchtet,
dann lege ich euch das jetzt gerade sehr ans Herz.
So und jetzt mache ich folgendes: ich packe mir 2 Packungen aus
und werd' sie erst mal klein schneiden und dann hebe ich sie nochmal unter den Teig.
Als nächstes füllt ihr den Teig in eine 20cm Springform, die ihr mit Backpapier auskleidet.
Und der Double Choc Boden wird jetzt bei 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze im vorgeheizten Backofen
für 45 bis maximal 48 Minuten gebacken und anschließend lasse ich ihn vollständig auskühlen.
Bis gleich!
So, weiter geht's! Mein Boden kühlt gerade ab und ich nutze die Zwischenzeit
und mache jetzt meine klassische Sahne-Creme.
Später beim Auftragen werde ich die Creme aber noch mit roter Grütze verfeinern. Jetzt erst mal zur Creme!
Wichtig ist - ihr kennt das schon von mir - alle Zutaten sollen kalt sein.
Ich hab sogar gerade die Schüssel und den Aufsatz einmal für 5min in den Kühlschrank getan.
Das hilft enorm, glaubt mir!
So und jetzt gebe ich alle Zutaten rein.
Wie gesagt: ihr findet sie unten in der VIdeobeschreibung!
Ich starte mit Frischkäse, das ist Doppelrahmfrischkäse - nehmt nicht die fettarme Variante!
Gebe ich direkt in die Schüssel. Da kommt noch Mascarpone dazu, Sahne, Puderzucker
und Vanilleextrakt. Und dann fange ich an, das zu rühren und geb dann nach und nach Sahnefest dazu.
Und unsere Creme ist fertig! Als nächstes werde ich den Boden durchschneiden
und zwar 2 Mal sodass wir 3 Böden erhalten.
So und wenn ihr ganz oben angelangt seid, dann lasst eurer Kreativität freien Lauf!
Ich habe mich jetzt hier - ich weiß gar nicht, wie man's nennen mag -
ich hab mich jetzt hier für ein Muster entschieden, das sieht so ein bisschen aus wie eine Blume
wenn man von oben schaut, ne?
(H: Joaa!)
Joaa! Und jetzt möchte ich die halt optisch auch nochmal ein bisschen aufpimpen mit frischen Früchten
und natürlich den Double Choc Waffeln damit man auch weiß, was innen steckt.
Et voilà!
Fertig ist unser Naked Cake. Ich persönlich finde, dass jetzt jeder aus der Familie
eine Komponente mindestens hat, die er mag. Wir haben Schokolade, wir haben Sahne-Creme,
wir haben Früchte, wir haben Vanille, wir haben eigentlich alles!
Also ganz schnell nachmachen und mir eure Fotos zuschicken! Noch besser:
Postet sie mit #kikiskitchen und taggt mich drauf auf Instagram weil ich freue mich immer, wenn ich eure
Kreationen sehe und sie dann auch reposten kann. Ansonsten wie gesagt alle ganz genauen
Informationen hier unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Hinterlässt diesem Video auf jeden Fall ein Däumchen nach oben und ein kostenloses..?
(H: Abo!)
Abo damit ihr auch solch genialen Rezepte nicht mehr verpasst!
(H: Und probiert auch unbedingt mal diese Kekse, die sind echt lecker!)
Ja, probiert sie unbedingt aus!
(H: Die schmecken echt bombe!)
Die zergehen richtig im Mund! Und ja,
ansonsten freue ich mich, wenn ihr bei meinem nächsten Video auch wieder dabei seid!
Tschüss, eure Kiki!